>> My name is Debadeepta Dey.
I am a researcher in
Microsoft Research AI in
the adaptive systems
and interaction group.
So, today, we are co-organizing
this session on AI
for AI systems.
Just a little bit of background,
my background is actually
neither systems,
but it's actually machine
learning and robotics.
So, there is a fun anecdote
I always like to
say from my robotics days
at Carnegie Mellon,
I was once part of
a team that was
building a big
self-driving vehicle,
not exactly a road vehicle,
but an off-road vehicle.
There were a large number of
sub-teams and there was this
one sub-team which was,
let's call them the
rock detection team.
The rock detection team decided
that our aim is
to build the world's
best rock detector so
that self-driving cars
won't drive over them and
we can avoid them and
do path planning and
everything pretty
reliably and robustly.
So, they very quickly built up
the first nominal version and
this rock detector was good.
It was on our test datasets,
proprietary test datasets, they
were like 70 percent accurate.
So, to not hold up the rest of
all the modules that were being
developed by all the other teams,
they decided that, okay,
we will push this out,
let the team work with that,
and then we will come back
and we will try to improve it on
the side while the rest of
the teams are using
this in the pipeline.
So, six months later,
they suddenly come back
and they say, "Hey,
we now have a 98 percent
accuracy rock detector
and it works great,
and we have the same
function signatures
and API interfaces,
so just drag and drop this
back into the codebase,
we'll do a pull request
and you're good."
Right? So everybody
was very happy,
and they went and they pulled
from upstream and then the
system just broke down.
This is a theme we kept seeing
over and over again that
as each individual module
was improving locally,
the entire system would degrade,
and we realized that
the systems that we're
downstream from it or sometimes
of an upstream from
it were learning to
compensate for different
distribution of outputs.
When I joined MSR, and
was in Eric's group,
and Eric and me have always had
this long discussions about
how we build systems nominally,
and the systems we
just like build them,
we try to do our best
to optimize them,
to make them as fast as possible,
but our systems don't reflect,
they don't adapt really and
do limited computation,
the concepts of
bounded rationality,
and the fact that we will
always have partial information
and finite compute
especially on Edge,
robotics, the new classes
of doing machine learning,
serving or training as fast
as possible, interactive systems.
So, I feel like this session
is very timely,
because just as systems has now
enabled a new revolution
or the new boom
in AI so as to speak
and big data is now
really big data and
new hardware and new chips,
new systems are being enabled,
there's also
this question of how do
you use AI to build
better AI systems,
so it's like kind of
a nice self-referential loop,
and hopefully, we will take off.
We have an exciting lineup of
speakers to talk about
all sorts of themes
related to this.
First of all, we'll
start with Eric.
Just as a brief introduction,
Eric is the director of MSR AI
and he also heads all of
Microsoft Research and we're
very pleased to have him
start off and then he will be
followed by Virginia Smith,
who is just starting
as faculty at CMU,
talking to us about like
machine learning in the Edge
and how to do Federated
learning better and then
we will have Behnaz from
the Systems Groups at
Microsoft Research and she
will tell us about how
machine learning is
being used and what are
the problems in
networking databases,
VMs in the cloud and
in really true big systems
how to do troubleshooting better.
Without much further ado, I'll
hand over the mic to Eric.
>> Thanks.
I think I have a mic that
I'm actually wearing.
So, for many years,
since my dissertation work,
I've been fascinated
and intrigued
at models of reflection
in AI systems.
What I mean broadly by
that are representations
and inference strategies
that actually
look at existing uncontrolled
or unmoderated AI systems that
come to control them
and optimize them both
for different kinds of
distributional settings,
shifts for example,
stream of instances,
varying amounts of time
available for computation to
generalize the ability
of an agent to do
well in the open world.
So, thinking more deeply about
potential architectures of
intelligence that might involve
one or more layers of reflection,
including reasoning about
reasoning or metareasoning.
I thought I would just mention
four topic areas today
that I think are
interesting directions in
the realm of reflection.
Learning to control
inferential processes
given a base process,
the idea of using portfolios of
components to build
more robust systems,
metareasoning for
ideal allocation of
resources for this idea
of being more flexible
to distribution of
problem instances as well as
to a utility function,
for example, overtime,
time criticality,
and then talking a little bit
about policies and
predictions for
speculative execution,
executing with available
resources now about the future.
These are all obviously
interrelated topics.
So, first on this idea of
learning to control
inferential processes.
So for me, the canonical problem
in this realm was some work we
did that was published at
UAI which was looking
at a theorem prover,
looking at NP-Hard problems
to satisfy ability,
constraint satisfaction problems,
and other related problems.
We had access to
a theorem prover,
several theorem provers actually,
and the basic idea
was we would be given
hard problems and then
we'd run the systems
and the community noticed
that a solution could
be found very quickly
or take a very,
very long time, I mean
like many, many varies.
In fact, there's actually
a halting problem as
well with some of
these challenges,
and it was unclear
if we actually knew how to
discriminate problems that
would go fast versus slow.
On top of that, we had access to
this idea of randomization of
a seed that would start
a new version of
an analysis of a problem.
So, when you start
a theorem-proving problem,
you can let the system
run and run and run.
At some point in time,
you can say, "You know what,
I'm going to stop this
and restart it with
a new randomized set of
settings and try again to
try to find a solution."
It was noticed heuristically by
Carla Gomes actually and
Bart Selman that
you could actually,
by taking a whole workload
of instances and running
into a theorem prover and
moving a restart time
for the distribution,
just like keep on moving it.
When you restart, you throw
away all your investment,
so you're hoping to find
a short run that will solve
your problem at
the cost of many runs,
and then heuristically setting
these system and you say,
"Well, I wonder if we could
do better than that."
So, the basic idea was we said,
"What might we do from
the point of view of
a machine learning
problem to basically look
at this in a Bayesian
way," and we first said,
let's look at the instances
and try to characterize
the actual instance
by featurising it.
Let's actually, insights itself,
let's featurize the environment
where this generator that is
generating the instances,
and then when you
run this system,
lets take a whole
pattern of evidence,
like actually we featurized
the actual search tree.
What's happening in
the initial part of the run
here and how long
has it been running
became a feature as
well without finding an answer.
So, that can be part
of your feature space.
Magically, I remember that I was
actually running
WinMine on an airplane,
cut off from the world
in those days,
with this big dataset
traveling across the country,
and we discovered there
was actual rich signal
in the actual evidence
being spewed from
the theorem prover.
You can read about all the
distinctions in the UAI paper,
to build a model that
would predict for any run,
will this be a short or long run
in advance of the run completing.
Actually, this led to
a body of literature,
I mean of several papers,
where we showed you
could actually use
machine learning to
take a very hard,
sort of a NP-hard problem,
and cut through
the hardness space with
Bayesian inference about when
to restart and randomize
and showed how you could extend
the power of one of
the hardest AI problems we know.
Theorem-proving.
That's one example.
Another example of reflection,
I think we need to
think more about as
a community is how do
we take portfolios of
solutions and putting them
together in
a coherent way to make
more robust reasoners and
the canonical version of
this for me is
a face-tracking problem
that I worked on many,
many years back, but
it actually also
resonates with today's work
going on even in this room,
I see best guys who work
in this space as well
to understand
context-based performance.
An incidence-based performance
of a machine learning
problem for example.
In this case, we're looking
at a face tracking here.
The idea is to take successes and
failures and build a
model of confidence,
which is so important in AI
systems in the open world.
In this case, we had
an algorithm of a certain type
that would actually provide us,
we were interested in
the inferred state
where the face was,
there was the idea of ground
truth which influences that,
and then we had this idea
of some interesting
variable here,
a very important one called
inference reliability,
real-time reliability
of inference.
We couldn't see this
directly in our algorithms,
but we can actually view what
we called reliability indicators.
Each algorithm we tried had
different reliability
indicators and
a bit with a different model for.
Now, it turns out
that we could use
different kinds of
approaches in those days,
color-based model, motion
decay model, we called one,
this idea of
background subtraction,
but the fun thing was we
built the model for each,
we learn a model for
each of these things
woven together and
boom we had a much more
reliable face tracker.
What I found most interesting in
this approach for
the portfolio is,
there's an independently
developed algorithms, of course,
that you can find dependencies of
various kinds and how they work,
but I was excited reading
about this in the paper,
in that we were now handling
unmodeled situations
in the open world.
So, for example, we never
really trained the system
on this problem of facing away
from the camera or
a jolted camera
or a peripheral distraction
of a person walking through
the scene or turning
lights on and off.
But, you see since these are
very different algorithms,
this led to the initial
intuition as to how
we built the system to
begin with this approach.
You see, in different settings,
one or more is fuzzing out,
but the reliability
indicators are quite
robust to capture
and wave, and say,
"I'm not doing well right now",
wait things to the inferences
from the other system,
and in the end we ended
up with a robust output.
Just a generic approach
to taking through
the possibility to do this with
other algorithms in
the future, especially,
independent cuts on
a problem that each managed,
and for each we have
a reliability signal.
Now, I'm meditating for
resource allocation.
This is a really
powerful direction
for system for
building these days,
and I'll get into
that in a minute,
but I want to go back
in time for a bit to
my own dissertation work.
I was very excited
about this idea of
thinking through what I used
to call object level value,
and then comprehensive
value of any inference in
the world when you subtract
the cost of reasoning,
the cost of delay.
So, let's say we have an
algorithm that's producing,
given some utility function,
with computation time.
This upper curve
here, in this case,
is showing monotonic
increasing with decreasing
marginal returns and the idea
of some notion of the cost of
delay in this case, linear,
and if you just consider
a very simple model,
we subtract the cost and
the value it's on the same scale,
you end up with idea of
a net value of action
with time looking like
this middle curve here,
and you see that an
ideal stopping time
and an optimal amount
of value you could
squeeze out of this algorithm
in this current setting.
If you made the cost of time
a little bit more urgent,
it will be more critical here,
but costly this linear
sensing because it could
be any kind of function,
you end up pulling back
the amount of time you should
be dwelling and how
the ideal value you
get out of the system.
Now, of course, for
the distribution here,
this is all uncertain
and that's where it
gets interesting.
The expected value of
computation, for example.
So, when we exercise
this system was to build
approximation algorithm for
probabilistic inference
and other NP-hard problem,
it turns out graphical models,
and with time here when
algorithm called bounded
conditioning would
solve decomposed version of
a Bayes net problem with cycles,
and you can see over time
the upper and lower bounds
are converging.
In this case, it was actually
urgent medical inference
where patient is standing
by with gasping for breath,
and our systems
actually is predicting,
at any moment, if I
invest this much more
computation in the system,
here's what I can
expect the balance to
do per being converged,
turns out that you
don't know where
the bounds in
this particular algorithm,
you don't know where
the bounds are going to be,
you just know how tight
they're going to be.
So, you're uncertain
and you can innovate
over that and compute
the expected value of
computation for 10 more seconds
or five more seconds computation,
and therefore have
a stopping rule when
the expected value
computation goes to zero.
Now, these methods turns
out stimulated working in
part if they cite the old
work in the AI community.
In psychology now, and people are
finding these kinds of
curves very similar
notions right now in humans
and other primates
studies that have been
done in terms of responsiveness,
cost of the urgency of a setting,
and the ability to do
well with incrementally
with more time.
But, a little bit an
application now of this
the cut from
the modern variants or
that it's exciting mean
and this is work led
by Dey, and Dan Bohus.
The idea is sticking through
a challenge we have,
an opportunity to
build what we call
Integrative AI systems
that have many components.
In particular, these kinds
of systems that can
do learning and inference
about a social setting,
for example, how many people
are in front of me?
Are they talking to me
with their attention?
What's the next dialog step?
What are people saying?
Natural language processing,
speech recognition,
acoustical analysis of where
the sounds are coming from and it
seems like the
assistant by my door,
which after, how many years
do we take down?
Seven years it ran straight
helping people, mostly straight,
out complain when
it was down like,
"Where's the assessment?"
and we got it back up again.
But anyway, here's an example
of one of these systems
but you get a sense for
the kinds of things that you
need to do in these systems.
Face tracking, listening in
this quiet video because
there's a soundtrack here of
how an agent what
might work with people and
the same thing with in
this case with physical
incarnations that are
physically embodied
robotic settings.
A lot goes on that
requires multiple components
to work with one
another and so there's
a platform were
building and it'll be
a workshop on this
platform in a week or so,
a week or so is a good
enough approximation theory
yet from looking at Dan
who leads the effort,
the Psi effort, which stands
for platform for
situated intelligence.
But, the idea is to
build a platform and
programming model and
execute it with my runtime
that can make it easier for
developers to build a system that
can take in multiple
sources of input,
so it's multimodal with vision,
speech, sound, acoustics,
and so on, and then have
many pipelines that
do a sense, think,
act kind of loop where
timing is very
important including
calling for Cloud components,
multimodal timing
uncertainty, and
now looking at meta reasoning.
So, quick example here that they
put together leading this effort
on the meta reasoning challenge.
We have these general graphs of
components that
call each other and
call upon one
another, for example,
a system that might compute from
lidar camera and
radar steering angle,
brake force, and accelerator in
a semi autonomous vehicle.
Might be some loss function,
function of latency and accuracy,
and we might figure out, well,
how do we want it prioritized and
look at the trace between
how well each component is doing,
how much precision we need versus
its latencies that might affect
the whole system and for
the throughput of the
system that's captured
by a loss function
in the output here.
One example that's what we're
exploring is slightly
of a face detector
and landmark
recognition component
where an image stream comes in.
There maybe four
different algorithms, let's say,
and we want to have some notion
of computing latency and
quality, but right now,
we're going to focus
on latency and it's
refined this context
dependent in terms of
in this case the number of faces
is seen and we're looking
at two different settings
here and what they did is work
and Dan worked very hard
to characterize how well,
how fast a system can
respond with a square,
a bounding box around the face
are given different
algorithms and given numbers,
different numbers of
faces in a scene,
zero to four in this case
in terms of milliseconds.
If we actually give this
system come up with
a utility function here in
this case around
450 milliseconds,
we basically design
a system that penalizes
the overall function
of the system based on
time after this
ideal target point
and know when to reason
about build the system
that can she learn this
automatically from streams,
and so they approach right now
that's being explored is having
a metareasoning module
that's actually
based on the theory
around contextual bandits
That watches and observes and
tries to pick the right
algorithm in this case.
Here's the really fun part.
There's a ResNet-50
model that's being used,
looking at the raw video
seem to just give
this contextual
bandit rich context.
So, it in some way
sees how many faces by
the features up to
the n minus one layer
of the ResNet-50.
Then it also looks at
the loss function from
the utility model as it works,
and the contextual bandit
runs mostly inference,
but it also does an exploit
but also does exploration.
So, it's actually
studying all the time.
So, as an example
of the video here,
there's a stream coming
into the face tracker.
Algorithms for three here,
you see the middle curve here
is the actual choice
of algorithm.
The top is the actual
loss function,
and the bottom curve is showing
the entire system latency.
Going from a single phase
right now to multiple faces,
and you'll see that
these all probes are actually
the exploration phase
of the algorithm.
But, what happens when it
gets a bunch of faces here,
the algorithm shifts to
optimize expected
the utility based on
the utility function here.
It gets interesting because
it's a pipeline now.
It shows a mini pipeline,
but you can imagine a feature
having a big graph now,
given the bounding box going
to landmark detection
five points,
27 points, 87 points,
more precise landmarks
on a face we need
for doing detailed tracking
and understanding of the face.
The same basic setup now,
and what you see here now
is an analysis now of
looking at two modules,
and so you're going
to see we now go from
to 12 different algorithms
because it's a combination now.
But again, going from
many faces to one face,
the system is in real-time
doing all this learning and
responding with
the contextual bandit.
Based on some theorems and proofs
done about what we expect from
contextual bandit models.
The long-term goal here
is to take a big graph
someday built inside.
Let's say, the
preferred platform of
choice for integrative AI, TM,
and automatically have a system
adjust how long
each module works with
sub-algorithms being selected to
overall optimize the performance
of the whole system.
Just briefly, I'll end
by saying that I've
been fascinated
by this ideal models of
computation anxiety.
What an agent should be worrying
about when it has
a little bit of idle time,
even when it doesn't
have idle time.
So, the example that
I often give is
a trauma care surgeon is
working on a patient,
and a speaker lights up,
and there's a multiple
casualty case coming in,
ambulances and
a family coming in,
and the trauma care
surgeon might stop
or slow down this
particular case to start
directing resources for
that next case coming
in as the ambulance is
on its way in or
multiple ambulances.
So, even my reason about
when you slow down,
what you're doing
now for the sake of
your overall life history of
your responses to a stream,
for example, in this case.
So, reasoning about
probability distributions
over what's happening
in the future and
speculating is important,
and there's some nice theorems
and ideas about this,
that actually would
apply to speculation,
more generally in
the systems world would be so
important in systems
often done heuristically,
taking algorithms
from the AI community
and applying them in this way.
If you could do what
we call continual
computation using every single
moment ideally over time,
given your current tasks and
a probability distribution
over future tasks.
To me, first of all,
that's a real model of
intelligence because
we're not here to solve,
most of us, one
problem and then die.
We're here to survive,
and have a rich long
history of successes,
and we want to always be
dreaming about the future,
trading off the now for
the future and being ready for
the probability
distribution of what's
coming next, and it's nice.
Given some basic assumptions
about distributions
and about our value of
pre-computing them,
we can do quite a bit with
optimizing our life histories.
So, these ideas have
been applied to
prefetching of webpages to-pre
computing sets of questions
that you might ask
in a medical diagnostic system,
where it's really hard
to compute for example,
the value of information.
Applying this to navigating
through a geo database,
for example, very quickly,
where you get a sense
by a trajectory
where someone's going,
and you get a sense for
a probability
distribution of needs,
and potential page
hits and misses,
or even a gaming engine.
I'm not in the Cloud
where you know the rules
of the game, you
know the graphics,
you know the needs, and
you can actually start
to use these principles
to fetch ahead.
One application that
we're very excited about,
I went from old research to
last week publication at PNAS.
They just published this work,
and this work came
from some work from
1998 in SIGCOMM 2007 and
Triple AI and now, PNAS.
Building on the same set
of ideas but the idea is,
and I'll end with
this concept here,
very core notion in systems.
How do we keep a cache fresh?
Think about this, or in
the same challenges,
how do we keep our index
of the web fresh?
How do we run a web crawl?
It's a very
interesting problem of
an agent in the open world,
multiple agents.
The idea is, you have, let's say,
if we look at the web problem,
many pages with some
knowledge about
page change rates based on
their properties in
history potentially,
and you also have knowledge
about how popular page is.
What's the utility function?
It's a function of
how all the pages,
of the cost, and how often
it's been to be looked at.
Turns out that, to
solve that problem,
it's generally a very hard
optimization problem
Cho and Garcia-Molina
showed for small n,
how to optimize that problem,
and as our here with you,
all of myself [inaudible] with
some interesting new results
have showed an n log,
n version of this,
that's running at
99 percent optimal.
It's the randomized
probabilistic strategy.
It's amazing we take this.
This is for synthetic data,
but we're now,
let's just say, Andrei is
trying this out with real data.
Andrei [inaudible] right
now working with us.
But, this upper curve
here is opt and
it's N log N methodology as well,
showing how well we can do
with a probabilistic
continual computation policy.
Very exciting. So, they're
rich opportunities in
applying AI for AI systems,
and I was going to say
AI for systems as well.
Getting down to the bare metal,
which is refreshing a cache.
Thanks very much. We're taking
quick questions now or-
>> Do we have time for
a couple of questions? No?
>> Sorry. So, this
should have been in
that potpourri,
something for everybody.
Yeah. Oh hey.
>> If nobody ask, I will ask.
You and I have been in
this business for a long time.
So, you ended your talk
on a very optimistic
futuristic fashion,
I am more concerned about who
knows how long I will be around,
and so I'm more concerned
about the next 10
years, let's say.
I am a little concerned
that in that respect,
we are a little exuberant and
over-optimistic because
what you as a company,
and I as a customer want,
is some guarantees that what
you are going to give me,
will work, not 99 percent but
10 to minus three percent.
I am a little disturbed,
especially coming from Academia,
that we sometimes oversell.
I am disturbed when I hear
that we can recognize
with 85 percent.
When I was young,
and we did simple
pattern recognition,
that was not
considered the result,
and you must remember that.
So, I am a little concerned
that we don't show
that under what conditions we
can guarantee that
this will work.
You started your lecture
with robustness.
Okay. Then, you abandoned
that word at the very end.
But I really think that
in order for us to get
credibility in
the population at large,
we really need to go back to
the guarantees and robustness.
Sorry I hope I did.
>> Well, we should have
a long discussion about this,
but let me start by saying,
I only abandoned robustness
because that was one of
the first topic of
four in 25 minutes.
It's a very important topic
for the community,
and there is
two approaches to it,
several approaches
let's just say.
Let me point out the work
by Bessemer and Mushi.
Right now, just given a paper at
each camp which is building on
a nice rich history of work
which is really dissecting down,
introducing new levels
of accountability to
machine learning for
well-calibrated and
reliable error signals
based on context.
So, it's a very
important area for
us with just hasn't
been announced yet,
but we're kicking off
a significant effort with
MIT Sea sale called
trustworthy and robust AI.
So, we're not abandoning
that topic by any means.
Of course it was
the first topic of my slides.
>> Come to us, that's what we do.
>> We're very close with our
Berkeley friends as well,
and there's more discussion we
had about that by
the way but offline.
So, and the other comment is,
if you have a well-calibrated
error signal,
it probably doesn't
make a difference
how poor your inferences,
that just changes
the application,
and the design, and
the appropriateness
of using a technique.
The hard problem is being
aware and sensitive,
and having subsystems
and super-systems that
understand how to compute
to the reliability signal,
and where this is
a very powerful and important
area for our research here,
and we can talk more
but that also offline.
Thirdly, I'll say and then I
would go on for a while now.
Microsoft has been a leader
externally co-founding
the partnership on AI,
where just today I tweeted,
if you want to look for my tweet,
The working group on safety
and reliability published
its first documented,
it's charter publicly.
That group happens to be
a multi-party stakeholder group
involving civil societies
as well as technologists,
but this is a very
important topic.
I'll say that at Microsoft,
we have what's called
the ether-committee,
AI ethics in effects in
engineering and research and
safety and reliable systems
was one of seven working groups
very active co-chaired by AJ,
Kumar who's been working
in space for a while also.
So, you're asking the right
people to be the concerned.
I think is we're actually ready.
It's a good concern and
we're with you on it.
So, now we'll talk about
briefly later, offline.
I just want to say
that when my PhD,
students when they
present their results,
the standard question I have,
"Don't show me what you can do,
show me what
your system cannot do."
>> Right. As a warning to
the whole AI community,
people that do duplex demos,
or whatever demos you want to do,
and the people who who call
out the problems of the AI,
it's easy with
probabilistic systems
to do a complete video
and expose of how
terrible a system is by
picking some examples,
and how wondrous it is
if you just pick
the good examples.
So, we want to always be
cautious about that and give
people a good representative
understanding how well things do.
That's part of even coming for
the reliability score I think.
So, I break great question,
and we'll have a longer
discussion maybe later about
that but I am getting
the sense that
I'm actually giving Virginia
even more time than she needs
usually for heavy problems.
>> So, thank you very much Eric.
So, next we have Virginia Smith,
and she is going to be factored,
into she already
actually started as
faculty at Carnegie
Mellon University.
She's just finished her thesis
with Mike Jordan in Berkeley.
We're very excited
to have her here.
Thank you for flying
out from Pittsburgh.
I know it's hard,
because I used to go
to grad school there.
Yeah, [inaudible].
>> Thanks. Can everyone
hear me, okay?
Great.
Yes. So, I am excited to be
here. Thanks for
the introduction.
Today I'll be sharing some
of my work in developing
system-aware optimization methods
for the federated setting.
So, the motivation for this work
and for a lot of my work is
thinking about
the machine learning
workflow and trying to
make it more efficient,
and more robust,
and more reliable.
So, what do I mean by
the machine learning workflow?
This is a very coarse
description of the workflow.
You start with your dataset and
a problem that you'd
like to solve.
Let's pretend it's something
with cat pictures,
that tends to happen a lot.
Under the hood, then you select
your machine learning model.
Then, to actually fit
that model to your data,
you often have to select
an optimization algorithm
to actually train that model.
Okay. But often this workflow
is not happening in isolation,
it's happening together
with some system.
This system and the parameters
of the system have
a very large impact on
the optimization
algorithm that you
select to fit your
model to your data.
So, one area that system
aware optimization
has a great potential to
really improve things,
is the federated setting.
So, in Federated Learning, this
is just a term that's been
coined to describe the problem
of training machine learning
models at the edge.
So, as opposed to a traditional
Cloud-based training,
where you might be storing
a model on the Cloud,
and training on the Cloud,
when it comes time
for prediction,
you send raw data
from the devices,
and then you get
the predictions from the Cloud,
here we're trying to push
some of the computation
and offloaded onto the
devices themselves.
So, you can store that,
the models on the
devices and you can also
perform training at the edge.
So, what that looks
like is, instead of
actually shipping the raw data,
you can send downstream
model updates
and aggregate them via the Cloud,
and then come to consensus on
some global model that you
shipped back to the devices.
So, this is becoming
more and more
feasible as devices grow in terms
of their computational
capabilities.
It's a nice thing to do, because
it allows you to quickly
incorporate new data that
you're seeing on the devices,
it also helps to
reduce the strain on
the network because
you're not having
a ship this raw data,
and it helps to increase
the privacy guarantees
that you can provide.
Again, because you're not
shipping the raw data,
you're shipping these
downstream model updates.
So, what are some examples of
applications that fit
into this setting?
You can imagine things
like language modeling
for speech recognition
on mobile phones,
adapting to pedestrian behavior
in a fleet of
autonomous vehicles,
or predicting health events like
low blood sugar from
wearable devices.
So, not all applications from
the IoT setting fit
into this setting,
but many do and
the key assumptions are
that the local data that's being
generated on each
device is important,
potentially more so than
some proxy data that
you could use if
you were training this
model just in the Cloud.
For the problems that
we're looking at,
we're looking at
supervised problems where
labels need to be available,
and then another reason why
these types of problems
are becoming more and
more interesting,
is that privacy is often
a very important concern,
and so not having to
ship that raw data for
applications like this helps
to enable privacy guarantees.
Okay.
So what makes
this problem difficult?
Why is it difficult to solve
optimization problems in
the federated setting?
In particular, why is it that we
can't use traditional distributed
optimization methods that have
been developed over
the past decade and
more that have been
developed for the data
center setting?
The issue is that traditional
data center distribute
optimization methods face a suite
of new challenges when looking
at the federated setting.
So in particular, in the
federated setting communication
can be more expensive than
in a data center setting.
So, you might have rather
than hundreds to
thousands of machines,
you might have thousands
to millions of devices in
the network and
the network itself
can be slower than
a traditional data center,
so you can imagine
a mobile phone network
where some of the phones have
very poor network connection.
Additionally, there's
a huge amount of
variability in the
network itself,
so you might have as
compared to a data center
setting where you might
assume that most of
the machines have
similar computational power,
here you could have
some devices that have
very different computational
abilities than others.
You might have certain
devices that are very
old versus very new devices,
some that have
very low battery power,
poor network connection and
then these things
can really affect
strugglers in the system and can
also affect issues
like fault-tolerance.
So at any given
around in a network
with a million devices
you can imagine that many
of them if you're trying to do
some sort of computation are
offline or trying to do
some other sort of computation.
You can't count on them for
computation every round,
so fault tolerance is
a big issue in the setting.
And I'll note that
this heterogeneity,
this variability
comes not only from
the system's perspective but
also from the statistical
point of view.
The issue here is
that we're generating
data on these devices
and we're also trying
to store and process that
data and so some devices
might generate
much more data than
the others and this can
lead to very unbalanced data
across the network.
So, the statistical unbalance
presents issues in terms
of how we actually
solve this optimization
problem but it
also presents issues in terms
of how we model the problem,
some particular
personalization is
very key in this setting.
The data that's being generated
on each of these devices,
can be generated in a very
non identically
distributed manner.
So you might have
certain devices that
generate data that's very
different from the others.
For example, if we're
thinking about trying
to develop voice
recognition models,
my voice recognition model
may be very different
than someone else's because we're
generating different
sorts of data.
So in the talk today,
I'm going to talk about
two methods that we've developed
recently to try to handle
some of these challenges,
one is FedCoCoA which is
a method for handling some
of the systems challenges in
the federated setting
and the other
is MOCHA which is something that
builds on on these ideas
to also allow for
personalization.
So first, in terms of developing
a distributed optimization method
for the federated setting,
again, what is the issue
with using something like
a traditional data center
distributed optimization method?
Well, this is a question
that I ask myself because
this is what I spend a lot
of my thesis working on.
So for example if you look at
some results from
the data center setting
with state of the art methods,
you'll see results like this.
So on the x axis
here I'll be showing
the time in seconds and on
the y-axis the distance
to the optimal,
so the goal is to get down to
the bottom of this plot
as quickly as possible.
What you see in the data center,
is that if you compare
a method that have
been developed in tune
for this data
center settings such as
CoCoA which was the focus
of my thesis work,
you can get these massive
improvements over
other traditional methods like
mini-batch Stochastic
gradient descent
or mini-batch coordinate descent.
So for example, for this problem
in this cluster this
was a 40th speedup,
it meant that the
training time went from
two hours down to
just roughly three minutes,
so this makes a big impact in
terms of your overall
training expense.
So these methods work well
on the data center setting,
let's see what happens
though when we when we
apply CoCoA to
the federated setting.
So what you see is in terms of
the time in seconds here
to get to the optimal,
CoCoA is not really
doing that well
and in particular it's not doing
much better than
these other baseline methods.
The reason for this
is that there are
these additional constraints
and challenges of
the federated setting that
have not been well modeled
by this optimization method.
So what we'll show you today is
basically how to
improve upon this
with this method that we're
calling fedCoCoA to get
these very large
performance improvements.
So, I'm going to backtrack
a little bit now and talk
about how CoCoA works
to show you where
it's falling short,
which allows us to develop
this more tailored method
for the federated setting.
So the motivation for CoCoA comes
from the fact that there
are two sort of extremes
currently and thinking about how
to perform optimization
in a distributed setting.
So, the goal again is that
you have a bunch of data
that's distributed on
different machines or devices.
So imagine each of these dark
gray rectangles is a data point
and each of these
light gray squares
is either a device or a machine.
The goal is to process all of
this data and to try to
find the optimal machine
learning model knowing
that you have to
communicate back and forth with
each of these devices
at each round.
So how can we perform
this communication?
On one extreme, you could take
something basically
that works well
on a single machine
and try to sort of
naively parallelize it into
the distributed setting.
This would be something like
a traditional mini-batch method,
mini-batch stochastic
gradient descent for example.
This method works
by at each round
selecting a data point
or a subset of
data points at
random and computing
something like a gradient
from those data points,
sending those updates
back to the master,
applying them to the
model and iterating
doing this over and over again
until convergence is reached.
So these methods are
very popular and
they're nice because we have
nice convergence guarantees
about these methods,
but in general they can be very
slow in the distributed setting
because you'll be
communicating very
frequently between
the machines and the master.
So what else is there?
On the other extreme,
there are methods known as
one-shot communication schemes
where instead of processing
one data point or a few,
you process all of the data
points completely,
you completely solve
separate models on each of
the machines and then you
do something like
average them at the end.
So, this is the other extreme.
It says never communicate only
communicate once at the end.
It's great because it's really
fast but in general convergence
is not guaranteed.
So you don't have the same
nice theoretical properties
that you do from
the mini-batch methods.
And putting this together,
the nice thing about CoCoA,
the reason that it is
a great method to use and
the data center setting,
is that it helps you to go
between these two extremes.
So in particular, CoCoA takes
this one system parameter
of how much you do
local computation
versus communication
and it exposes it to make it as
flexible as possible
so that you can tune
this amount of local computation
versus communication.
How is CoCoA actually doing this?
So the method is
actually very simple,
basically what it
does is that the goal
is again to find some model
across all of the data.
How can we do this? We can take
this global problem and
split it into subproblems,
one for each machine.
So each machine is trying to find
some solution to
its own local subproblem.
It tries to find some updates to
that subproblem sends those
updates back to the master,
applies that to the model and
then iterates doing this
over and over again.
But the thing that makes
CoCoA really flexible,
is that in performing
these updates to
the local subproblems,
it makes the
following assumption.
It assumes that each
of these sub-problems
is solved to accuracy theta.
So this theta parameter
is really flexible
because theta is
just a number that
can go between zero and one,
when theta is equal to zero,
it means that all
of these problems
have been exactly solved on
each device whereas if
theta is closer to one,
it means that you are in
exactly solving the solution,
perhaps you're just doing
one or two updates locally.
So by tuning this parameter,
you can tune roughly
the amount of
local computation
versus communication.
So, this seems like
a great setup to use in
the federated setting
where you have
this issue of
expensive communication.
However, there's one issue
with this theta parameter,
which is that theta
is not truly that
flexible and that
you have to set it
once for the entire method,
so this theta parameter
is consistent
across devices and
across iteration's.
The reason that this
is such an issue,
again is because
we have issues in
the federated setting with
statistical heterogeneity.
Some of the subproblems might
be harder to solve than
others which would affect
this theta parameter.
You might also have issues with
systems heterogeneity so some
of the devices might not
be able to compute good
solutions to their subproblems
because they're not connected
to the network they
have low power,
low battery level or just
their hardware is worse than
the other devices in the network.
And finally you can
also have issues with
devices actually just
dropping off and going
offline and that's
not accounted for in
the original CoCoA
method because in CoCoA
we don't allow this parameter
to exactly equal one,
meaning that you have
to send some update.
So, what do we do it in
federated CoCoA to handle this?
Physically, we make
this simple change.
So we change theta to
be something that you
can vary both by iteration and
by device and this looks
deceptively simple
but what becomes difficult
is actually showing
that the method
can still converge
given that you've done this.
What we're able to show is that,
using this much more
flexible accuracy parameter,
with the simple assumption that
the same device does
not send information
every single round,
so you'd have to eventually
get an update from one of
the devices otherwise
you won't be able
to reach the optimum.
We can show two convergence
guarantees one for
Lipschitz losses,
this is something like
the support vector machine
model you get
a one over epsilon rate
of convergence
and you can get a slightly
faster rate of convergence for
smooth losses things like
logistic regression
or linear regression.
Okay, so this is
nice because now we
have this setup that is much more
flexible and more tailored to
the federated setting and we
have nice theoretical
convergence guarantees about it,
but how does it
perform in practice?
So what we've done
is, we've gathered
some real federated
datasets from things
like sensor network,
Google Glass data,
human activity recognition
on mobile phones,
and you can see what's
interesting is that
these real federate datasets
really are quite heterogeneous.
So you can see that the
minimum and maximum number of
data points per device really
does change significantly.
For these datasets, I'll just
show one example of the results.
You can see that federated
CoCoA in terms of
the time in seconds
is able to converge
much faster than
traditional CoCoA and
these very popular
mini-batch style methods
which are used frequently
in the distributed setting.
So in particular for this
problem that we were looking at,
we're able to converge to
the same epsilon
accurate solution,
two orders of magnitude
more quickly.
What was interesting is
that we also got to look
at what would happen
if we just drop devices
out of the network.
How would that change
the performance of the
method and what you can see
is that as long as we don't
drop out one device
every single round,
which is what is shown in
this green dotted line,
the performance of
federated CoCoA is
fairly robust to this issue
of devices dropping out.
Okay. So, I want to
talk briefly as well
about what we've done to
handle personalization.
So, going back to this,
this workflow one thing about
the federated setting
is that it's really
impacting not only how we solve
this optimization problem but
also how we model
the data itself.
Okay. So thinking about how
to model federated data,
two extremes are, you
could imagine just
selecting a separate model
for each of the devices
in the network.
This is nice because
it allows you to
personalize the local data
that you've collected,
but it's not great and
that you can't really
learn from the other devices
in the network.
If you're learning
a separate model
for each of the devices,
then you're not able to aggregate
the information and learn
across the devices.
On the other extreme,
if you learn
just a single model
for all the devices,
you're helping to learn
from the peers in
the network but you're not really
personalizing the
information that you have.
So what we want is
something in between.
We want to be able to personalize
our models but also learn from
the aggregate
information and boost
the effective sample size
of each of the devices.
So, how are we doing this?
One nice way to set
this problem up is
through something called
multi-task learning.
So in multitask learning
you do exactly this.
Basically, you're trying to find
some local model for each
of the local datasets.
These local models
are all captured in
this aggregate matrix
W. Then what
the objective is
doing is basically
enforcing that these models
follow some structure.
Restructure is enforced to
this task relationship
matrix Omega.
So the reason that this is
really nice is that you're
trading off between
trying to find
the optimal models for each
of the devices as well
as enforcing some structure
across those models.
So this allows you to have
personalized models that
also share and learn
the structure across them.
So this set-up for
example can capture
things like all of
the tasks being related,
most of them being related but
there being some outliers,
clusters or groups, or
things like asymmetric
relationships.
For example you might have
a power user in the system
that is performing most of
the interesting information.
So you can capture relationships
like that as well.
Okay. We looked at using
a multi-task set up with
the real federated
datasets that we've
collected and what we saw
is that the multi-task
set up compared to
the completely global or
completely local models
consistently got
better prediction error
in terms of the problems
that we were looking at.
So you can see
this right-hand column,
each of these prediction
error numbers
are significantly lower
than the other two models,
and this makes sense because
the multitask setup is
really able to go between
these two extremes
of the completely
global or completely local model.
So, with this in mind,
the key question then was,
how can we take this nice
multi-task learning framework
and apply it to some of
the federated CoCoA work
that we had,
that is looking at
trying to actually solve
this problem in
the federated setting?
So, in particular we
want to be able to solve
this new broader objective
in the federated setting.
If we're looking
at this objective,
one thing that's
nice is that if you
solve for these two terms,
competing terms w and Omega
in an alternating fashion,
Omega is in fact
quite easy to solve.
You can solve that
just with the models
w but without access to
any of the federated data,
but w is what needs to
be solved in
the federated setting.
So the key question was,
how can we extend
this update to W
to work with a federated CoCoA or
method that we had
described from before?
Okay. I missed the key idea
of how we actually form
these sub-problems when I was
describing them earlier
and this is really
important if you want to
think about extending
it to another type of objective.
So, recall that
the way that federate CoCoA
and CoCoA work is that
basically you have
some global problem of interest,
the way that you actually
solve this global problem
is by splitting
into sub-problems,
one for each device.
So the way that this division
is happening is
actually very closely tied to
the mathematical formulation
of the objective function.
So in particular, what we
do in CoCoA, which is nice,
is that the primal problem
here is a bit difficult to solve.
It's a bit difficult
to distribute
this into separate sub-problems.
Because you have data points
that are touching each of
the models of interests,
w. So what you can do is
instead of looking at
this primal formulation,
you can say consider the dual.
So this is a very common trick
that's often used
in optimization.
Because this problem is convex,
the dual will still arrive at
the same solution as the primal.
But this dual is actually
much easier to
separate because you
have one dual variable
per data point,
and so this separates much more
nicely across the machines.
Okay. So, what I'm saying is
mostly true except for
this regularization term
here and the way that
we handle that in
CoCoA is by doing a quadratic
approximation to this term.
So essentially
what's happening is
that at each iteration,
we're computing
a quadratic approximation
to the true objective
in the dual.
Okay. So that's the secret sauce
in the back of how we're
actually taking this problem
and distributing it
across the devices,
but it's important
to consider this
because then
the key challenge is,
how can we take the same idea
of using the primal and the
dual and apply that to this
multitask learning objective?
Okay. I'll just summarize
this quickly by saying,
basically we can do
something very similar
where the dual of interest
looks like this and we can
define a sub-problem very
similar to what we had done
in CoCoA and federated CoCoA,
where basically we're looking at
this dual and forming a
quadratic approximation
around it.
Okay. So putting these all
together just to recap.
This was nice because
we addressed some of
these key challenges in
the federated setting
that really differ from
the data center setting.
In federated CoCoA,
we handle things
like expensive
communication by taking
the problem and putting it into
the sub-problems that are
solved to approximate
accuracies and we allowed
these approximate
accuracies to be
highly variable which helps
to deal with
systems heterogeneity.
Then with MOCHA,
we also looked at
the statistical issue of
personalization and we
show that we can take
that model and also
apply this similar ideas
as in Federated CoCoA.
So, end with two quick slides
in terms of where
this is going next.
So, I'll note that
there are a lot of
other exciting areas and
open research opportunities
in federated learning.
So, one is that the problems I
talked about today
were all convex.
Deep learning is also, of course,
very popular and is non-convex.
So there are interesting
opportunities and thinking about
how to extend this for
non-convex setting.
There are a lot of
interesting open problems
to deal with privacy and security
around the solution like this.
So certainly federated learning
improves upon sending
just the raw data but those model
updates you also want to make
sure that those are secure.
We talked about personalization
through multitask learning.
There are other ways to provide
this like transfer learning
or model fine-tuning.
We reduce communication by making
this accuracy parameter
very flexible.
There are other ways to
reduce this even further,
things like compression
or lazy aggregation.
Finally, in terms of
the machine-learning pipeline,
I've been focusing on
the training portion.
There are of course other ways,
you could think about addressing
the machine-learning pipeline
in this edge scenario.
Things like doing on device
feature extraction or
on device inference.
So, there's a lot of
open and exciting research
directions within this area.
Okay. In terms of
my own research,
I'll note that one thing
I'm excited about is you
may have noticed some of
the federated datasets that
we were looking at were very
small and so we've
been working with
some collaboratives
to develop something
called LEAF which is
a benchmark for federated data.
It will contain a suite of
open source datasets and
evaluation framework
to help frame some of
the statistical and systems
metrics and questions
and it will be online very soon.
So, please check back
on my website because
we'll be releasing in
the next few months.
Sorry, last thing, so
there's been a lot of
exciting work around
systems and machine
learning obviously at the summit
today and within this session.
I myself, I'm serving
as program chair for
a new conference on systems
and machine learning
called SysML.
So, SysML, the goal of
the conference is to elicit
new connections between
the two fields and to make
sure that these discussions
are happening not siloed within
their own research communities
but in a collaborative way.
So, this last year,
we held a one-day conference with
over 300 attendees
and 200 submissions.
This next year 2019 will be
a full conference three days
with published proceedings.
So if you're interested in
that, please take a look.
The submissions are due
at the end of September
and the conference
itself will be in
Stanford in the end of March
through April of 2019.
So, I think that was
all I had and I'd
be happy to answer questions.
So, I had a question
about the privacy aspect
of the Federated approach.
I mean, it seems to me that,
if I'm worried about
the privacy of my data,
then it should only
be used locally,
and especially if
it's going to be
for our personalized model,
and not be shared at
all with the Cloud.
But sending model updates,
it seems to kind of like
open a whole kind of worms,
with like model inference
attacks and things like this,
but it's not really clear,
you're not going to be
leaking basically raw data.
>> Yeah, that's
a great point. I think
there's a trade-off there.
If privacy is the most
important thing to you,
more important perhaps than
the accuracy that you're getting,
then certainly it makes sense to
keep that data completely local.
The main thing that
the Federated setup is positing,
is basically that sending
model updates is
a better alternative,
than sending the raw data.
Which is what's frequently done
in an a Cloud-based situation,
where you have the
model in the Cloud,
you're sending the raw data
up to get predictions.
So, I agree with you that,
the model updates themselves
could also be an issue.
So, there's some
interesting work looking
at combining that with
differential privacy,
to ensure that the
model updates that you send,
are in fact private.
But, I think that
there's a trade-off,
because if you keep
all the data completely local,
then you're losing some of
the interesting
information and data,
that you could get from
devices like yours.
So, yeah.
>> I have a question about
the personalization.
So I'm not a machine
learning person,
but can you give some examples?
I'm kind of trying to
understand what the limitations
of it is, in terms of,
is this about different phones
having different types
of sensors,
or people having
different preferences?
>> Yes, I think
the example I gave
before was that- for example,
if you're trying to train
a model for voice
recognition on your phone.
If you train a single model for
voice recognition across
all voices, it could be that,
that doesn't perform as well,
as one that's personalized to
the specific voice of
a specific person.
So, certainly there are
some aspects of speech
that are going to be the
same across all people,
but you could also imagine
that certain aspects of
the way that a person
speaks or their accent,
also influence
speech recognition.
So, that's the trade off,
where you want to do
some global modelling,
but also have some amount
of it that is local or
personal to the data. Thanks.
>> Thank you very
much. Then, we're
going to have our next speaker.
I am very excited to
introduce Behnaz Arzani.
She is from a MSR as well.
She's going to tell us about
Self-managing networks,
and hopefully will not have
any networking
problems over again.
Except we have A/V problems.
>> Is this doesn't
work, it seems like.
>> You have to-
>> I did.
>> What do we have to do?
>> I have one in
my bag, I can use mine.
Let's see. I can use my own too.
Let me Google.
Actually, this is recognizing
it. Let me grab mine.
This is in bag.
My bag isn't there.
Okay, I can just use mine.
>> Okay. Sorry everyone.
So, today I'm gonna
be talking about,
this as more of a
networking talk.
I'm not really
a machine learning person,
but what I want to talk about is,
how we move towards networking
to manage themselves.
What I want to do is,
sort of talk about what I
learned through my research,
about where machine learning can
actually help in networking.
So, the picture I've here
is of Albert Greenberg.
He is the head of
Azure networking.
He has 1,029 reports,
and if you look at
what these people
do on a day-to-day basis,
a lot of their time is spent on
managing and
configuring networks.
If you think about when
networking as a field started,
the first paper on
networking was a 1973.
SIGCOMM started in 1969.
SIGMETRICS has been
around since 1971.
Then NSDI started in 2004,
and yet we still need people to
actually actively configure
and manage your networks.
So, what I wanted to do,
is to try to understand,
"Why do we still need this?"
Like, why are people
spending so many hours,
and so much money, just on
configuration and management.
So, what I'll do, is I'll
talk about what my research
and collaboration with Azure
over the last three years.
What I'll describe is,
what I've learned to be
the cause of this problem,
and where machine
learning can come
into play to help solve it.
This has a couple of
different aspects.
One aspect is diagnosis,
the other aspect is security.
Then I'll talk about, what
are the common themes,
and how can actually
I help with it.
So, I borrowed this slide
from Amin Vahdat,
who's basically the counterpart
of Albert in Google.
According to him, availability is
the main foundation on which
our datacenters are built.
So, we want them
to be manageable.
We want them to be performant,
but if they're not available,
we did get none of
that benefit anyway.
So, the first thing that can
disrupt that, is
going to be failures.
Failures are going to
hurt our availability.
To give an example, why it
is a diagnosis is hard,
is think of this scenario.
You are a researcher,
you want to use a Cloud.
You pull out the Cloud VM,
you go over the Cloud network and
then you connect to some service.
So, when something goes down,
if you imagine that the network
is is managed by Azure,
and then the service could be
managed by some other company,
the problem that this causes is,
when you have a failure,
you can have one
of two situations.
Either, someone accepts
responsibility for the failure.
So, either network operator
looks at their networks
and figures out,
"Oh, I know why this happens."
Or, on the other hand,
the service operator
looks at their system,
and finds the cause
of the problem.
In that situation,
you can eventually
figure out what was
the root cause and solve it.
But often, you run into
this particular situation,
where the network starts
blaming the service.
The service blames the network,
and nobody really wants to
take responsibility for this.
We had a real example of
this happening in
Azure networking,
where we had VMs
that were connecting
to virtual storage
panic and reboot,
because their connections
to storage were failing.
In these situations,
we had tickets created
that were basically showing
customers are being impacted,
but nobody was willing to
take responsibility for it.
So, storage was blaming network,
network was blaming storage,
and the problem was
not getting resolved.
So, the question was,
how can we actually attribute
blame to the right team?
So, we created a system that
was published in SIGCOMM 2016,
we call it NetPoirot.
The main requirement for it was,
that it didn't require
anything to be
installed in the
network or storage,
because neither one
of them wanting
to have that overhead,
but we'll still be
able to say who is
responsible for the failure
when the failure happened.
What we decided to do,
is take advantage of
a network protocol called TCP.
Now, TCP is designed
to be able to detect
network failures.
It is designed to be able
to give you reliability,
when you're going over
a best effort distributed
system that is not guaranteed
to deliver all of your packets.
But, in our theory was,
if it's designed to detect
failures in the network,
can it distinguish between
and failures on the server side?
So, we took a bet.
What we did was, we
designed the system over,
that looked at TCP statistics
we gathered from the host,
so it doesn't gather
any data from
the network or the service,
and try to identify if we have
a client-side failure or
server-side or network failure.
So, the way this system worked,
is we had a monitoring
agent that was deployed on
all hosts across Azure
or Azure datacenters.
We injected failures
onto a subset of
these machines to look at
what failures look like,
in terms of TCP statistics.
Then we trained
a simple Random Forest model
using this data,
to see if we could
actually distinguish
what was causing the problem.
Then this model was running
on each of the host
to figure out why
the VM is rebooting.
It turned out to work
really, really well.
So, while we solve that problem,
we still have one more,
which was, okay, "Now,
I know that I have
failures in my network,"
and it turned out
actually 20 percent of the time
those failures were
in the network.
Then we ran into in
separate situation where,
you could have multiple links in
your network having failed,
or be dropping packets at
any given point in time.
You can actually have a link
with a high drop rate,
and link with a slightly
lower drop rate.
But, you care about
one of them more.
Because while the link
with high drop rate is
dropping a lot of packets is
not impacting any customers,
or the customer is not noticing
that packet drop rate,
versus this other
lower drop rate packet
is impacting customer
whose application is very,
very sensitive to
this type of failure.
So, what we wanted
to be able to do,
is associate failed links
with the problems
that they're causing.
So, essentially,
we wanted to say,
this customer is impacted
by that link failure.
This customer is impacted
by this link failure.
Now, here we actually didn't
use machine learning,
but I'll talk about how we
actually solve the problem.
But, before I do that,
I'll talk about why
it's actually hard.
So, in an ideal situation,
what you want to do is say,
this is the connections
that this guy has,
these are the connections
that this guy has.
If I know where my failures are,
I can basically map
the failures of the connection
and then solve the problem.
But the problem is
operators don't always
know where the failed links
are either, right?
If you think about the scale
in which datacenters operate,
this is becomes
an extremely hard problem,
is basically like finding
a needle in a haystack.
The thing is, we also
have packet drop rates
that are obeyed
because of the normal
day-to-day operations
of the network.
So tail drop rates,
detecting them doesn't
really give you anything.
You can't take any action
on those types of problems.
So, one-off, transient
drops do occur on
many links and they add noise
to the diagnosis problem.
So, the requirements that
we were asked when we were
solving this problem was to be
able to detect
short-lived failures,
to be able to detect
concurrent failures and we
wanted the approach to
be robust to noise.
But again like
the previous approach,
we again had this mandate from
the network operators
where we were
not allowed to deploy anything on
the servers or anything
on the network.
So we had to again
use an approach that
was only on the client side.
So, the strawman solution
to this would have been
something that is traditionally
networking known as tomography.
The way it works in
this example is the following.
If you have a simple topology
where the link between 4
and 2 is bad and you
have three connections,
you can basically
assign a variable.
Let's assume you know
the path of each of
these individual connections
for now, right?
You can assign
a variable to each of
the links and you can form
a system of equations
that equate 0 if there's
no fail link along
the path and equate
1 if you have a fail link
along your path.
By solving this
system of equations,
you can basically
figure out which
links in your network
have failed.
So, the easiest reason
why this fails is that
you don't always have
enough flows to be able to have
a full solvable set of equations.
There are more problems beyond
this where we're now
working standpoint
in the sense that it's really
hard to have a path of
every single flow in
your network and a lot
of other things.
I won't go into the detail
of that to bore you,
but we had a system we call
007 that was published in
NSDI 2018 that basically
tries to solve this problem.
I will just give you
a teaser of how it
works and the way it works is we
have again an agent
that's only on
all hosts in Azure so
it's on the client side.
It monitors TCP connections
running on these hosts.
Every time there's a packet drop,
this agent gets notified
that a packet drop
happened and the host
then vote on the status
of the links.
So, the way the voting
works is in this case,
this connection didn't
experience any failures,
all links get a vote of 0,
1 and 2 and we actually have
a theoretical guarantee that
this is supposed to work,
that is resilient to noise,
all of the stuff that
operators care about.
Now, in the context of security,
I've also been looking now
at a problem again in
collaboration with
Azure networking and here this is
a completely different flavor
than what I was
talking about earlier.
What we want to be able to
do is to detect compromise VMs.
It's a very simple problem
and if I have
anti-malware on all of my VMs
in an ideal situation,
I really don't have a problem
anytime my VM gets
compromised the.
Anti-malware should be able
to find it and I'm good.
The problem is that in reality,
this is what the
system looks like.
A lot of customers
don't want to have
a Microsoft owned
anti-malware software
on their machines.
So, a lot of these VMs
are not protected.
So, then the question is
how do I protect those VMs
because these VMs
can now cause damage to
other VMs that are running
in the same data center?
The way we ended up deciding
to do this was based on a theory.
We thought that
if compromised VMs
live in network footprint,
then maybe the connection graph
changes significantly enough when
a VM is compromised from
its past behavior for us
to be able to detect it.
So, this is ongoing work,
but right now,
the results seem
rather promising so we
don't know if it
will work or not,
but what I want to do
now that I've talked
about the general scope
of the problems
I've worked on is,
sorry, one more slide.
What are common themes across
these problems and where
machine learning
can actually help?
So, before I go into that,
I found this RFC for those of
you who work on networking,
you know that RFCs are basically
standards in networking
and they're basically
is from 1996.
So, it's even before,
I think I was five
at that point maybe,
but I feel like this truths
that are said in
that RFC still hold.
So first of all, some things
in life can never
be appreciated or nor
understood until you
actually do it yourself.
One of the things that I've
learned after three years
of collaborating with
Azure networking has been,
until you experience
the problems and if you
don't have the domain knowledge,
it's going to be really,
really hard to create
a solution that
the operators actually want
to use and is practical.
The second thing is
it's always possible to
have multiple separate solutions
to the problem and
try to combine them,
but when you work with operators,
one of the things that
you would notice is that
they always prefer
the simplest solution.
You can provide complex models
that work really,
really well in theory,
but in practice,
an operator should be able to
verify why your model
is not working.
So, if I'm an operator
and if I look at
a number coming out of a system
and I don't know what it means,
if a system gives me a wrong
number at one point in time,
I'm going to lose confidence
in the system and
I'm never going to
use it again and
that happens a lot.
So, going back to the original
question I asked which was
why do we need operators to
manage our networks today?
There are a couple of reasons.
First of all,
the ideal data that we
need to figure out
the cause of problems
is often missing.
The monitoring we need
is expensive a lot of
times and so one place that
machine learning can really,
really help is
figuring out when and
where to initiate monitoring
of what type of data.
The other thing is gathering
the right data can be
expensive so that's another place
where I think we can contribute.
Sometimes it's not even
clear what the right data
is to figure out
the source of a subset of
these problems and there's
sometimes like the case
in network which
we found is that
there is data that
indirectly points to
the cause of the problem,
and sure causality is important,
but sometimes correlation is just
enough and it's
all that you need.
So, to sum it up,
this is where I
think AI can help.
If you can predict when a
failure is about to happen,
we can always figure out
what monitoring to turn
on and what that
monitoring should be.
If you can identify where
the complex correlations are,
sometimes it's the case that you
can't avoid operator involvement.
Sometimes operator is needed to
solve the problem but
if you can identify
when that help is actually needed
and when the alert is noise,
that would reduce pain
in complex platforms
like Azure by alot.
So, with that, I'll end with
this other truth that I find is
important to keep
in mind. Thanks.
>> So there's a lot
of new work coming
out in [inaudible] It's
a very hard topic in
the machine learning area
that now working on
interpreting the output of
the models including
deep learning,
sorry, whether deep learning
or otherwise like
how do we interpret
especially like
complex decision trees
and everything, right?
Do you find that kind
of work still being
useful or is still too far away
from like really
helping this domain?
>> There's two ways I
find this useful and
one of them is
lightly idiotic and
the one that I find it most
useful is when you want
to build operator trust in
your system or in your model.
It helps if they understand
why and how the model
is working or when it's not
working why isn't working, right?
That is a place that I think
that's very much needed.
I've seen a lot of systems
built by Azure networking
themselves where the system
is deployed, it's very useful.
It makes a couple of mistakes
and people are like "Oh,
the system is crap, we're
never going to use it again."
That's not really true
but it's like people
lost confidence in the system so
they're never going to
use it again, right?
So, that's one thing but
the other thing I think is
sometimes like in the case
of the TCP stuff,
the Neporo stuff that we did,
you can gain a lot
of knowledge about
the protocol itself or
about the fundamentals of
the system itself from
the explainability of the models
like what we learned was
a lot about how TCP
reacts to failures on
the server side that we
didn't know before we
didn't expect to see.
So, that was also something
like and that's part
of the reason we
use decision trees
because they give
you explainability but yeah,
so those are the things I
think where this can be used.